so I definitely want to know um I I have
seen Sly work and he likes to control
slash direct things when he is on set so
I am curious what he was like when you
were filming the series knowing that
about him
exactly the same sometimes he can't help
himself he comes out when we're
shooting a scene he turns into
director's line and goes the lighting I
asked to be one of that lens 35 you know
shouldn't be
and shouldn't we be looking over the
shoulder and I'm like it's a reality
show it's not looking anything good
start over and we're like
it's not how it's supposed to go yeah
ignorance would have been Bliss but
unfortunately you know too much you
gotta stick your two cents in no
completely you want to obviously make it
as great as it can be yeah and you have
the experience behind the camera thank
you now I think that's also important
the next season hopefully will make it
even more cinematic
Chase
I'm so curious when it comes to like a
reality show like this how much are you
discussing before filming begins with
the producers and the network like
what's off limits what you're willing to
talk about and how much is it sort of
being found in the edit and then you're
discussing I don't really feel
comfortable with that scene but that's
okay oh wow you said that's a mouthful
because the edit is everything I'm a big
editing
affectionato and that you have to have
your like if the family has to get into
the editing room so everyone's on the
same page and quite often you have an
editor they're not with the family and
they'll put things in they think
are interesting and they just don't work
for us also when you're on the set after
a while the girls you know they start to
know what works of them what doesn't and
this angle doesn't work this lighting is
kind of harsh and eventually everyone
finds their own style and and I think
the crew itself
falls into that Groove and everything is
copacetic after that but
no the stories are totally real but you
do go I'm not going to say that okay and
I'm not going to say that because I just
don't think it's funny and I don't think
it's relevant and everyone you know you
know well I think every family every
family yeah even you everyone has
something private they don't want to
talk about so I think that that's a very
fair thing but I think 90 of it is
exactly who we are yeah it's just the 10
that we love to keep between ourselves
no I I by the way I I could never do
what you guys just did uh it'd be very I
give you a lot of credit for willing to
you know what I mean oh yeah
it was it was really hard because we
were growing up kind of not we're not
growing up in the spotlight so how
especially in front of the camera was a
big step especially like for me because
they have their podcast so they're kind
of used to it but it was really hard for
me at first and also you're in college
I'm in college I I yeah exactly no
nothing there's not a shy bone in your
body girl yeah
that's good though everyone here is very
animated you might say which helps
there's no really wall flowers in our
family so it's like it it wasn't that
hard if you if there was someone in our
family that was definitely didn't want
to do it then I would honor that but
everybody was excited to be a part of it
because we have a lot of funny stuff I
think it's a good idea you have a
reality show that no one speaks everyone
is so shy and that's it they go they
call it Big Mouth I was gonna make a
joke about that uh but Netflix thing uh
for soon to be fans of the series uh
what do you think would surprise them to
learn about the actual making of the
show it's a lot harder I think people
don't understand that there's probably
hundreds of hours of footage that are
completely unused hundreds no hundreds
and it wasn't one of those things were
oh we have a call time we show up 30
minutes and then leave we really put in
six sometimes seven days a week eight to
ten hour days also some storylines that
aren't finished yeah no and you have to
keep going back so I'm adding to the
storyline so it was just a lot of
a lot of time a lot of energy but it was
really nice being able to do it with
your people yeah because they're also
doing it with you so yeah it's a lot
more labor intensive I find than doing a
feature a lot more because it's
unstructured
and you just need to fill in oh God we
have to go back six months later we need
this thing here is it working we need to
approach this scene from a different
angle we didn't we need to voice over a
different narrative it's quite
fascinating it's a real skill set I I
yeah again I want to reiterate I
couldn't have done it um this is a
question for everyone but Sly uh if
someone has never seen uh a film that
he's done what is the one that you want
them watching and why it's like I've
actually had a boyfriend's tell me I've
never seen your a dad movie your dad's
moving into Thailand I think I would
want people to see either Oscar
because it was the only comedy he did
thank God just kidding the only comedy
or rhinestones because that was the only
singing movie about the cop what was it
what does that happen
yeah because it's funny everyone knows
there's one type of character but what's
it called she
cheers how about Rocky that might work I
think I think I think Sly is very
similar to Rocky out of all your movies
I think you're Rocky it's like Rocky
combination with Oscar because this is
so good you know what I'm saying oh gosh
oh you're gonna take me to the pet store
I had a turtle food you know the fact
that they make coffee I think I think
Psy is very sensitive and he's very
um he's very Soulful person he's a he's
a writer he's a reader you know and I
think that's like more like a rocky very
common very sensitive and caring and
loves to be with the family doesn't have
a lot of friends he keeps very immature
but then also he's like an Oscar where
he's super funny
you don't have a lot of friends here
like excuse me
a Quasimodo no friends no he has the
same friends he's had for 50 years that
that's a good thing because I support
them all no that's not true anyways
anyways he's a really funny guy so I
think Oscar's probably whatever what
stop okay sorry I know you're sorry I
asked that question okay real fast
because I'm just I'm out of time but I
just gotta have to ask you Sly uh I saw
trailer that you are um you feed someone
at the table which reminds me of
something that I do a certain animal and
I'm just curious if you're as much of a
pushover with animals as I am I'd like
to think I'm not but yeah they're in the
bed with me they're eating my toast
when we're actually eating off the same
Fork which is disgusting but true
yeah I am yeah how do you look at those
eyes and not give in yeah we have three
dogs and a cat at home so sort of a cat
yeah she's like half a cat half a cat
half human okay
it's true who cares about this cat he
cares about her cats no give him an
extra minute then give them a minute go
since we screwed up your interview I
actually do appreciate it um one of the
things that I always find fascinating
about uh reality shows is when you guys
have to sit in the chair and sort of re
recap what's happened or sum things up
how awkward is it to sit in that chair
and try to remember
um you know you know what I'm talking
about oh my God all confessionals I am
so oh God I get so hard they they're
asking me stuff from so long ago how did
you feel from like two I'm like I don't
remember how I felt three months and you
also have to speak as if it's happening
to you right now oh and then it's the
grammar that always messes you up too
yeah they're very uncomfortable that was
the last thing I gave into I said no he
wouldn't do it for the first few months
he was like I can't do it I won't do it
I won't do it and then he finally gave
in and he's like okay I'll do it if we
set it up in our backyard and then yeah
I said why and then all of them
the light went down and the lighting was
horrible and couldn't see him so then he
had to go into a Sound Stage so it was
pretty fun so my experiment was a
failure Outdoors did not work but I know
what you mean it's it's it's not easy it
really is because
sometimes you're that confessional is
the glue quite often that holds the show
together it's kind of like the narration
no 100 well listen uh I I hope it's a
huge success for you guys thank you for
giving me an extra minute and good luck
with the rest of your speed date